this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
please watch this entire video before
removing your catheter
this video will teach you how to empty
your foley bag and remove your foley
catheter
a foley catheter is a thin rubber tube
that runs from your bladder to a foley
bag that collects urine
a balloon filled with water holds the
catheter in place
a syringe removes water from the balloon
through the balloon port
removing your foley catheter involves
emptying your foley bag
deflating the balloon
and removing your catheter
you will need disposable gloves
a syringe for removing the water from
the balloon and a clean cloth or paper
towels to clean up spills
be sure to keep the foley bag lower than
your hips to allow the urine to drain
out of your bladder and into the bag
step one wash your hands with soap and
water and then dry them
step two hold the bottom of the foley
bag over a toilet
step 3 open the drain valve urine will
begin draining from the bag
empty the urine from the bag
step 4 close the valve
now you will begin removing the catheter
step 5
wash your hands with soap and water
again and then dry them
step six
put on disposable gloves
step seven
unclip the catheter from your leg
step 8 hold the balloon port tubing in
one hand
firmly push the end of the syringe into
the balloon port and twist until you
make a tight connection
water from the balloon begins filling
the syringe
step nine
when the balloon is empty relax take a
deep breath and gently pull on the
catheter to remove it
[Music]
do not pull hard if gentle pulling does
not remove the catheter contact your
health care provider
after you remove the catheter drink
plenty of water to create the urge to
urinate and ease burning when passing
urine
contact your surgeon if you have any
questions about your foley catheter your
temperature is 101 degrees fahrenheit or
higher
your bladder feels full but you see no
urine draining into the foley bag
you cannot remove your catheter with
gentle pulling
your urine is cloudy has a foul odor or
you see a lot of blood in your urine
it is normal to see a small amount of
blood in your urine after removing a
foley catheter
also contact your surgeon if you cannot
urinate within eight hours after
removing the foley catheter
you feel burning or pain when urinating
that lasts longer than 24 hours your
stomach feels bloated or painful
you feel the need to urinate more often
than normal
or your bladder doesn't feel empty after
urinating